[Applause]
[Music]
the sort of 20/20 in China has been
stormy er than the final days of
Brangelina or the relationship between
Donald Trump and Rosie O'Donnell news of
the economic downturn that has seen the
country record its lowest economic
growth rate since 1990 has been
compounded by the terrible impact of the
coronavirus events that naturally we
will be following and keeping you
updated about right here on visual
politic however on this occasion we're
gonna tell you about another major
threat facing the Chinese superpower a
threat that could completely change the
expectations that many of you have about
the geopolitical evolution of this
country no doubt you've heard of the
one-child policy while that same policy
which was once hailed as a vital and
unavoidable measure of her achieving
development has been completely
abandoned as it has created a situation
that now threatens China's role as a
global superpower and as you will see
for any country to maintain its
population without taking into account
any migratory movements a fertility rate
of at least 2.1 children per woman is
necessary that's what is known as the
replacement rate however the average
number of children hand by Chinese women
is only 1.6 and the birth rate has
fallen from about 20 births per thousand
citizens in 1990 to just over 10 in 2019
or in other words the Chinese day are
having half as many children as they had
just 20 years ago
a first glance all of this may seem
unimportant however the truth is that
the consequences of this trend could be
enormous especially in the field of
international geopolitics that's why in
2015 the Chinese government put an end
to the one-child policy and now well now
they need more children like there's no
tomorrow
[Music]
what's really going on what happens to
the one-child policy
why the sudden turnarounds and what does
all this have to do with China's future
the great demographic glitch everytime
politicians play at designing shaping
and building societies at will it's a
bit of cannon fodder for visual politic
the results they're often pretty dire
the one-child policy went from being a
relief to becoming an extremely heavy
burden but to better understand where
the problem really lies we have to go
back to the middle of the 20th century
at that time the Asian Giants had not
yet completed its demographic transition
that is women still had to have a lot of
children to compensate for very high
mortality rates basically it was the
typical scenario of any pre-industrial
society as a country modernizers
mortality rates fall much faster than
birth rates therefore creating huge
population growth
[Music]
it is precisely that gap that difference
between the fall in the birth rate which
happens very slowly and the fall in
mortality that explains the great
demographic shifts of the last century
and is for example what is currently
happening in many African countries but
there was something else going on in
China Mao's government actively
controlled the country's birthrate the
fundamental idea went something like
this
available labor was what caused economic
growth so the more workers the country
has the more developments that the
country would achieve the idea was
severely tested in the early 1960s when
the great famine cost the lives of more
than 15 million people the famine was a
result of the so-called Great Leap
Forward Mao Zedong's second five-year
plan after such a demographic
catastrophe the aim of the government
was to promote birth rates at all costs
[Music]
so through a variety of measures the
population increased by almost 400
million people in just 30 years and
that's the point when communist leaders
thought that the birth rates had got out
of control and that if such population
growth continued China would never
achieve development because the
population was growing as much or more
than the resources needed to maintain it
that's why in 1979 the Chinese
government decided to take a stand and
say okay we've reached a breaking point
we have a population well above our
means so now everybody will be limited
to having one child and if you have more
you're going to have problems and that's
how the one-child policy came in which
remained in force until 2015
only in some rural areas and in specific
cases was it permitted to have more than
one child but it is a policy that has
had unexpected consequences it is
estimated that during the time the
policy was enforced it ended the lives
of more than three hundred and sixty
million fetuses and newborn children the
reason on one and avoiding the sanctions
imposed by the government for breaking
the law and on the other hands the
cultural preference that existed in
China of having boys over girls
in fact this cultural phenomenon
increased the ratio of male to female in
some regions to 125 men for every 100
women it's the most uneven ratio on the
planet in short atrocities were
committed that have been harshly
criticized by human rights organizations
the one-child policy became the most
extensive social engineering operation
ever carried out
as you can imagine after almost four
decades of strict adherence to this
policy the consequences are enormous
they have left a deep impact on the
social structure of the country so let's
take a look
[Music]
China's numbers make no sense
Claire China should have stopped the
policy 28 years ago now it's too late
evokes young senior scientists at the
University of wisconsin-madison but why
does this scientists claim that it is
too late too late for what well take a
look at the following chart what you can
see is simply a radical change in
China's demographic structure a radical
change that begins with a devastating
loss of population this is the scenario
the country is going to face for decades
to come
[Music]
while the number of children under the
age of 14 will drop considerably
population aged 65 or over will balloon
over the next few decades and that's not
all
even more critically the working age
population is expected to gradually
shrink by about 200 million people 200
million fewer workers over the next 30
years and by the end of the century
things could be much worse in fact
according to China's own National Bureau
of Statistics the working age population
began declining in 2012 and in 2019
alone it shrank by nearly 900,000 people
to give you an idea this is how the
demographic pyramid is changing it's a
bit like what's going to happen in
countries like Singapore Japan or South
Korea with one important difference
China is going to face this problem
before it's a fully developed country
and of course we're the dwindling
working population and an increasingly
dependent aging population well it won't
take long for problems to appear China's
state pension fund to run driver 2035 as
workforce shrinks due to effects of
one-child policy says study South China
Morning Post and the problems don't end
there all the economic parameters may be
affected for example until now much of
China's economic growth has come from
incorporating more and more workers into
the productive economy however now that
is changing and there are already many
analysts pointing to this fact as being
one of the causes of its economic
slowdown
stop it off China is a country that is
still developing which means it has to
try and grow rapidly while facing all
these problems and that is not going to
be an easy task look for example all
that how things might be interest 30
years
[Music]
by 2050 the dependent population is
expected to be 80% of the working-age
population that means there will be four
dependent citizens for every five
workers in China but we don't have to go
that far into the future
a study of 323 companies in Szechuan one
of China's most populous provinces has
found the astonishing fact that nearly
58 percent of companies struggle to fill
vacant positions due to worker shortages
perhaps this is why we should not be
surprised that China is now the world
leader in industrial automation it
currently has more than 150,000
industrial robots in service
approximately 36% of all the industrial
robots in the world
in this way the Beijing regime hopes to
increase employee productivity that is
to maintain or increase production with
fewer workers so that a good standard of
living can be maintained for its
population and take note because it's
not the only country that sees robots as
a way of escaping its demographic woes
[Music]
it is exactly the same escape route that
is being pursued by South Korea Japan
and virtually every developed country
faced with rapidly ageing populations
only very strong productivity growth can
alleviate the serious economic and
social consequences of having a
disproportionately elderly population
the question begs to be asked at this
point is apart from robots is there a
solution from a demographic perspective
what exactly does the Chinese government
intend to do
[Music]
when the damage is already done
when the damage is done
reversing it is very difficult so many
years of social engineering have made
the Chinese population apathetic towards
starting families and it's not only that
the country's specialization in
productive industries is not helping
either
and they explain China has grown very
fast over the past few decades that
continues to maintain relatively low
levels of productivity this indicates
that the country is specialized in
competing with low labor costs in
labor-intensive industries to give you
an idea productivity per employee in the
United States is nearly five times
higher than it is in China that is to
say for every hour worked it takes five
Chinese workers to produce the
equivalents of what it takes one
American worker this also means that
shifts of 12 hours or more are not
uncommon in China China needs to change
its economic development model from
labor intensive and low quality product
production to the production of
high-quality good strong Xiao Chui
deputy director of the Institute or
China and global development Faculty of
economics and business of the University
of Hong Kong
the fact is faced with such a labor
intensive working environments having
children isn't so easy to squeeze in
so in a way these two factors the
gradually developed lack of enthusiasm
for families coupled with the intense
work environments are making the
abolishment of the one-child policy well
essentially useless and this is what
explains repercussions like fees
several Chinese provinces are
restricting abortions when until
recently they openly promoted them some
have even implemented the need for three
doctors signatures to be collected
before being able to carry out the
abortion what's more there are also
obstacles appearing which are making
divorce more difficult so will the
Chinese government be able to force
families to have more children perhaps
they will give privileges depending on
the number of children or restrict
access to public services or jobs if the
condition of having at least two
children is not met pay attention
because that's where this situation is
likely to end up the loss of a working
age population is an issue that can harm
not only China's economic development
but also its geopolitical ambitions
they're now at this point it's your turn
would you be in favor of a government
that forced its citizens to have more
children how do you think China's
demographic crisis should be solved well
leave your answer in the comments below
and I really hope you enjoyed this video
please do hit that like button if you
did do subscribe for brand new videos do
check out our friends at reconsider
Media who provided the vocals in this
episode that were not mine and as always
thank you for watching if you want to
learn more about politics and world
affairs and here's some more of my
lovely voice come check out the
reconsidered podcast where we don't do
the thinking for you find reconsider @ww
re consider mediacom or on Apple or
Google Play or your favorite podcast
you